is tech getting out of control well we
have two wild stories
china has reportedly developed an
artificial intelligence prosecutor
that's capable of evaluating crimes and
filing charges with stunning accuracy
and amazon is apologizing after digital
assistant alexa encouraged a 10 year old
girl to do a dangerous challenge
here's the mom describing what happened
what it actually told her to do was to
pull
um
plug a
phone charger part way in and then touch
the exposed proms
with a penny i was actually right there
in the room with her and i just i kind
of
was so freaked out i'm like no alexa no
unbelievable i had to get rid of alexa
because she was helping my son with his
math homework kaylee i know you're a mom
like me i wanted to get you i'm not
joking about that guys i wanted to get
your reaction on this because this this
truly is very dangerous and we know
there's a lot of other stuff with
tick-tock and challenges going on out
there your thoughts as a mom
yeah i got it rid of my alexa too leslie
but if you go in my house literally
every plug has a plastic cap in it
because i have a two-year-old and my
biggest fear is her trying to put
something in that plug as we know
two-year-olds eagerly try to do
including my daughter so the thought
that they could then listen to tick-tock
and be instructed to do this tick-tock
by the way owned by bite dance by the
way which is a china-based company one
last point this china artificial
prosecutor 97 accuracy maybe they should
look at oh i don't know china who's
committing genocide against an entire
people group the uyghurs just a thought
jj i want to go to you on china thank
you kaylee for the segway there um you
know are we part of this problem and is
this where we're headed with artificial
intelligence prosecutors because we're
using self-checkout even though many of
us technophobes like me often cry for
human help
you know i'd love to to really rip into
this one and obviously i don't want a.i
prosecutors deciding my fate but if you
look around the country as some of the
da's we elect and how corrupt some of
our local judicial systems are i mean
maybe it would be a step in the in the
direction of justice all i can think
about is the i think it's a tom cruise
movie it's a minority report where they
start arresting people before they
commit a crime which is kind of like
what we see with some of the purge in
the military that you were you're
friends with somebody we think you might
become a radical so let's go ahead and
kick you out i'm afraid that we're kind
of heading in that direction in this
country already
joe uh quickly um you know on to jj's
point about china do you think it's
almost impossible though for us to to do
this because the machines are only as
good as the humans who program them
that's an excellent point but i think
we're so relying on them more and more
that we're just going to embrace this
technology even if we're scared that
eventually robots will take over the
world you look at polls and something
like 70 percent of americans think that
robots will take over but i have to
disagree with you and kaylee on the
whole alexa thing i literally just told
my kid today swear to god that if you
have trouble spelling a word when you're
doing your spelling homework ask alexa
and she'll tell you how to spell it so i
think it could be a good thing sometimes
perhaps right use the tools you have
available
yeah don't come to me i can't spell
cat um on the amazon story because i i
love your answers they're very witty and
that's the and i would say lighter of
the stories but alexa um what's your
take as i think the younger member of
the youngest member of this panel uh
with uh with alexa amazon and tick tock
and these messages these challenges for
kids right i am also the the childless
person on the panel
i know i yes i have no children
i also have no alexa but i will say the
issue with you know technology and ai in
general is when things go wrong who is
responsible right i mean if i were to be
running around telling kids to put
pennies in sockets i don't think it'd be
good enough for me to just say oh my bad
i won't do that anymore there would be
uh you know i'd go to prison or at the
very least there'd be an investigation
so that's the question here when these
things mess up who's responsible for
that
and and you know what i know you don't
want to have kids after listening to our
parenting advice especially joe's nice
to sit down teach your kid to read teach
your kid to spell
anyway the fastest is up next hi
everyone i'm brian kilmeade i want you
to do me a favor i want you to click to
subscribe to the fox news youtube page
this is the only way that i know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
fox you can get it all here on youtube
so subscribe right now